So what is the engine of history?
I beg your attention.
There's a simple question for you.
Yeah.
What is the engine of history,
which I like on answerable questions
is the engine of history.
Politics.
Yeah.
The inherent natural,
eternal quest of people.
The bend,
other people's wills and take power
or is the engine of history.
Economics.
Yeah.
The grinding on the ground process by which people carve out livelihoods over
against other people's competition for the same livelihoods.
It doesn't seem to matter what history you study.
Oh,
where are you?
Look,
history always some somehow comes around to this nexus,
this collision
between forces of political power and forces of economics,
and our job is always somehow to discern between them and how they mix.
Now
often of course the answer is that it's all one in the same thing.
Listen to this passage by a Friedman and the south named Bailey Wyatt.
He got up and made a speech at a Freeman's political meeting.
This was actually an early union lead meeting in 1866 it was about political
organizing in the south.
Yeah,
but no,
what Bailey gets up and says as it was recorded,
it was a meeting in New York town,
Virginia Bailey Wyatt,
former slave.
He sort of announcing the freed people's grievances at a political gathering.
He says,
we now as a people desires to be elevated and we desires to do all we can to be
educated and we hope our friends will aid us all they can.
I may stay to all our friends into all our enemies.
We has a right to the land where we are located.
Why?
I'll tell you our wives,
our children,
our husbands has been sold over and over again to purchase the lands.
We now locates upon for that reason.
We have a divine right to the land and then didn't we clear the lands and raise
the crops of corn and cotton and tobacco and a rice and there's sugar and have
everything and then didn't them.
Large cities in the north grow up on the cotton and the sugars,
the rice that we made.
Yes,
I appealed to the south and to the north.
If I hasn't spoken the words of the truth.
Okay.
I say they have grown rich and my people are poor.
At a political rally
it makes an aggressive economic speech
about the labor theory of value.
He didn't read need to read John Locke,
he'd never read second treatise on government.
He hadn't had a political philosophy course but he absolutely understood.
He called it the divine right,
the labor theory of value if I Labor to improve that land,
it's mine.
In that in the simplicity and the agony and the beauty of Bailey,
why it's statement,
you have a lot of what was at stake in reconstruction and you have a lot about
what the political dilemma was and delivering on Bailey why its claim to a
divine right to the land.
All right back to Washington and back to the politics at least for a few minutes
and then I want to shift a south to this story of the on the ground economics of
reconstruction,
especially this massive transformation of a slave labor economy into some kind
of free labor economy.
That quickly evolves of course,
and you know this,
at least the contours over from reading phoner.
It evolves eventually rather quickly into a system of tenant farming in a system
of sharecropping and assist them ultimately have a kind of debt peonage.
But in Washington,
the political triumph of the radical Republicans comes in that veto proof
congress.
They produced in the fall elections of 1866 and in 1867,
they pass the first reconstruction act followed after that,
uh,
in 67 in early 68 by three more reconstruction acts simply called the second,
third and fourth reconstruction acts and it wasn't this system by which the
southern states,
the x confederate states,
we're actually readmitted to the union.
The great possibilities phoner addresses over and over in this experiment in
racial democracy,
this experiment in increasing democratic forms of government and institutions in
the south through the transplanting of the Republican party into those x
confederate states is rooted in this document.
Those are the five,
I don't know if you can read it in the back.
Can you read that in the back?
Yeah.
All right.
I love this machine.
It makes me look good,
but those are the five part I'm not going to,
well,
maybe I will.
The first part of the first reconstruction act divided the south into five
military district.
The second set,
these district would be commanded by a general,
not below the rank of brigadier general and inadequate and military force.
That part wouldn't ever really come off and the,
and then it wasn't even big gun.
Third commanding general,
what supervised a general would supervise the election of delegates to state
conventions and those new state conventions would write these new state
constitutions for the southern states.
Note the process.
Now this is not Lincoln's 10% plan and it sure as hell isn't.
Andrew Johnson's that portion who are loyal plan.
All adult males regardless of color who were not disfranchised for participation
in the war were eligible to vote and the constitutions had to provide for male
negro suffrage in the south.
You'll note the Republicans,
as I've said before,
are stepping clear of black suffrage in the north
and they're going to do it again and the 15th amendment.
We'll come back to that Thursday.
And finally,
when a majority of the voters ratified a constitution,
and when Congress approved it,
president has virtually no role in this.
This is congressional reconstruction.
Want to stated ratified the 14th amendment,
no choice,
the equal protection clause,
the citizenship amendment you must accept then and only then the state would be
readmitted to the union.
If you put it all in one large pill,
it's a very big pill for the x confederate states to swallow,
and at least politically on the surface,
it is exactly what they had to swallow in order to be readmitted to the union.
In between 1866 actually,
Tennessee was readmitted before this act even past in a shifty,
strange manner.
It had to be readmitted again after that.
But between 66 and 1870 the 11 former confederate states were readmitted to the
union under the radical reconstruction plan of the congressional Republicans.
Now,
those three subsequent reconstruction acts are very important.
And by the way,
every one of these acts,
including the renewal each year of the Freedmen's bureau,
the renewal,
I mean the,
the first civil rights acts,
15 different bills
developing a reconstruction plan passed by Congress were all vetoed between 1866
and 68 by Andrew Johnson.
I may have said this before,
more vetoes by a president of United States than all previous American
presidents put together.
You could call this a constitutional crisis.
It was,
you could call it a breakdown and federalism.
You could call it whatever you want,
but it's government by veto and override a veto every time.
Hey,
Jay vetoed a reconstruction act.
Congress in its two thirds,
majority Republicans in both houses overrode his veto.
We've never had a government operate like this with this many vetoes and
override vetoes in such a concentrated period of time.
That's how reconstruction was actually put in place.
Politically.
Second Reconstruction Act gave details for how those military commanders were
supposed to conduct their districts.
The third reconstruction act passed summer of 67 set up what were called
registration boards,
which were empowered to deny voting rights to anyone they felt were not taking
loyalty oaths in good faith is still trying to enforce this loyalty oath and the
fourth reconstruction act not cast until spring of 68 simply said that a
majority of votes cast would be sufficient to put a new constitution into
effect.
Not a majority of those southerners who had voted in 1860
you'll note some erosion there and the radicalism of the radical plan.
There are a lot of reasons for that,
not the least of which is they were in the midst at that point of trying to
impeach Andrew Johnson.
Now,
I wish I had an entire lecture all,
I do have an entire lecture to give you on the impeachment of Andrew Johnson,
but I'm going to do it quickly and I'd be more than happy in our review session
in a couple of weeks or any other time
to come back to it.
Okay.
It's the first great model we have of the impeachment of a president.
Of course in our history,
we've had another one since we used to think it would never,
ever,
ever happen again after the Nixon debacle.
Here I go.
I'm straying into my tangent.
Okay.
Believe it or not,
I was,
I'm giving away my age here,
but I was a high school teacher.
The Richard Nixon was almost impeached,
uh,
and I had prepared for months to teach my students about impeachment and in the
sob resigned.
It just took all the fun out of the early 1970s,
but it was a great civics lesson.
We got that civics lesson over again because of Bill Clinton's affair with a
White House intern
and because of what is or was or whatever the hell it was.
He said to the grand jury,
you need to know a couple of things though about the constitution.
If you don't already know it,
they're actually,
there are four,
well,
five provisions about impeachment in the constitution.
It's the most awesome power in the constitution in some ways and it isn't wheel.
The Very Austin
he authority or to impeach of course rest with the House of Representatives is
the House of Representatives through the Judiciary Committee that investigates
grounds for impeachment of a president or a cabinet official or a Supreme Court
justice.
It is the House of Representatives and that then brings articles of impeachment
which in effect are like an indictment,
although they are a political indictment and never intended to be a legal
indictment.
Okay.
The third part of the constitution,
Article One section three clause six gives the u s senate the power to sit as
the jury,
the judicial function of trying a person under impeachment charges.
The house charges the Senate judges
only the Senate and it's collective vote can determine guilt or innocence and it
takes they,
they kept this an awesome power and difficult to use.
It takes a two thirds vote of the U S Senate to impeach and remove a president
or other official and then comes to the punishment clause.
Article One,
section three clause seven of the constitution judgment in cases of impeachment
shall not extend further than to removal from office and does qualification to
hold and enjoy any other office of honor,
trust or profit under the United States.
But the party convicted chill nevertheless be liable and subject to indictment.
Trial judgment of punishment according to law.
Okay.
You could still be tried in a criminal court after your impeached,
although we've never gotten that far.
But the only power the Senate has his removal and that is exactly what the
radical Republicans are trying to do to Andrew Johnson and that he provokes them
to do over and over in 1867 and early 1868
there is one other feature in the constitution and that is of course the
president's pardon power president shall have the power to pardon in all cases
except impeachment.
No,
I don't.
You don't remember Gerald Ford pardoned Richard Nixon?
I do.
Probably
probably cost Gerald Ford election in brief what happened in the Johnson
impeachment
and he was impeached.
He simply wasn't removed from office
is what you had is a process through four and five different,
depends on how you count them stages and the political development of this
crisis of authority and power over who's gonna run reconstruction.
Now there are numerous theories,
historical interpretations about why Johnson was finally impeached by the
Republicans.
It never would have happened if,
if Andrew Johnson would have in any way just backed off and admitted that he was
probably going to be a lame duck president.
One theory is Johnson's personal behavior as an explanation for his impeachment
is personal habits were hardly fetching is a swing around the circle and the
fall of 1866 was an utter embarrassment to the presidency.
Is likening same self to Jesus is constant ranting on the radical Republicans as
traders calling them Judas.
He is called in the press a presidential ass at various times during that tour.
That's one part of it,
the sort of personal provocations of his style,
but a second explanation that I think holds much more weight is the Johnson and
the radical Republicans simply had fundamentally different constitutional
conceptions of the meaning of the war and the meaning and the nature of
reconstruction.
Policy Johnson,
you'll remember one at a rapid quick presidential executive reconstruction with
virtually no alteration of the constitution and utterly no changes in black
civil and political rights is 15 vetoes and the overrides of those vetoes in
that process of veto and override,
you really have the origins of the roots,
the essence of why the radicals finally decided the best thing to in their
political interest to do with Andrew Johnson was to remove him.
A third theory is,
and there's something to this,
although I don't think it explains it all by any means,
is what one historian has called the radical plot thesis.
Just sheer partisan politics to sheer partisan hatreds.
This guy was an old Jacksonian Democrat.
He was a southern Democrat as the president and the Republicans not only wanted
him out of the way of their reconstruction plans,
they wanted the democratic party ruined if they could do it.
Some of them did want that.
Some of the leaders of the impeachment movement in the house,
James Ashley,
Benjamin Butler,
George Boutwell and others where sometimes referred to even in their friendly
press as,
as one Republican paper put it as bail full of trio of buzzards has ever perched
in the House of Representatives.
And they were accused as sometimes politicians are accused today have a witch
hunt.
They investigated everything about Johnson,
his bank accounts,
allegations that he had tried to betray Tennessee during the civil war,
which were nonsense.
And even that he had somehow participated in the booth conspiracy to kill
Lincoln auto nonsense.
Um,
the real explanation here of the,
if there's,
if there's smoke,
I mean if there's fire where the smoke comes from on this radical plot thesis
against Johnson is this idea that there were some radical Republicans who,
who saw a big opening not only to,
to remake the south to Yankee eyes of the south and they aren't interested in
doing that and not always a bad motives.
South needed schools desperately.
It needed some kind of economic revival,
desperately needed.
It's Harvard's dredge desperately needed active as government to do all this.
But there was some radical republicans who saw a chance here to rearrange
constitutional powers to use the feeling at a broad against Andrew Johnson to
tip the balance of power toward the congress as never before in the nature of
the federal government.
Removing Johnson would be removing an obstacle to congressional hegemony over
And now there's some element here too that the fact that you need to remember
who actually would've replaced Andrew Johnson if he had been removed from
office.
There is no vice president.
He had been Lincoln's vice president.
We didn't have the amendment,
which comes later in the 20th century,
which allows a new president,
takes over to a point.
His vice president signed the absence of any vice president.
Who would it become president.
Okay,
come on.
Has a great trivia question.
You use this one out at the bar.
No one will know it
louder.
I can't hear.
You
know,
president pro tem of the Senate Bingo,
who was Benjamin Wei to radical Republican from Ohio and one of the leaders of
the impeachment movement.
A little unsavory.
You're organizing to impeach the president by the way.
I'll be the next president.
Yeah.
And fourth,
and last but not least,
what's at stake in the impeachment of Andrew Johnson?
I'm going to spare you all the sordid.
Did wonderful,
tasty,
lovely details of the corruption and skullduggery and scandal and payments that
went on in the final vote in the Senate that moves seven Republicans over to
acquittal and saved ajs hide.
I'm going to spare you all that wonderful,
lovely collection.
It's really beautiful,
awful ugly stuff.
Money offices.
If you read John Kennedy's profiles in courage.
I mean,
we all love to love Jack Kennedy and Ted Sorensen,
who was the speech writer,
was one of the greatest speech writers.
Everyone,
Ted Sorenson wrote that book profiles in courage than they put Jack Kennedy's
name on it.
And one of his chapters is of course about Andrew Johnson being persecuted by
the radical Republicans in reconstruction.
God,
they got that wrong.
But last but not least,
Andrew Johnson was impeached and the radicals kept going after him because Aja
wouldn't quit.
He kept provoking them,
provoking them,
provoking them and provoking and not just with words.
They would appointed general and one of the five districts in the south heat
firearm
congress would appoint a whole new series of Freedmen's bureau agents for Texas.
He'd fire them.
You can't run a government like that.
He would veto the Freedmen's bureau.
They override the Freedmen's bureau and they put the budget in place.
He'd say,
just go and try to enforce it.
Now,
what do you do with a president if you're drowning the congress and you're
trying to put a policy in place,
but at the heart hero was a struggle between a group of politicians capable of,
of serious corruption in their own way,
but nevertheless who are actually trying to defeat white supremacy.
They we're actually really trying to create some kind of black civil and
political rights in the south.
Surely wanted the those blacks to be Republican voters.
What else is new?
But Andrew Johnson's stood fast against them at every turn to try to preserve
his own particular vision of white supremacy.
No,
just one passage in his state of the union message,
December,
1867 this is after three attempts to three investigations of him.
They've already been done by the House Judiciary Committee and the House
Judiciary Committee has brought possible impeachment articles to a vote and yet
voted it down because it didn't quite have any smoking guns yet.
And what does he do in his State of the union?
December 80 and 67 among other things he says in the progress of nations,
I quote,
Negroes have shown less capacity for government than any other race of people
know,
independent government of any form has ever been successful in their hands,
wherever they have been left to their own devices.
They have shown a constant tendency to relapse into barbarism
and it got worse from there.
Steven's Sumner Wade and the host of the Republicans in Congress kept hearing
this over and over and over and finally they went after him.
The house finally voted in February,
1868 uh,
by a vote of about 140 to 50.
Something to impeach him.
Trouble was they actually,
I wrote 11 articles of impeachment,
but in essence,
the first nine were all about the technical violation of two laws.
The congress had passed that ultimately will be and should have been declared
unconstitutional.
They are called the tenure of office act and the command of the Army Act Tenure
of office act was a law passed in essence saying the president of the United
States could not fire members of his own cabinet.
The commander of the Army Act said the president of the United States as
commander and chief cannot issue orders to the army's without passing those
orders through the general of the army,
which was the 19th century version of the joint chiefs of Staff.
Yeah.
They were literally trying to strip constitutional powers away from the
presidency,
but from Andrew Johnson,
he violated the tenure of office that he violated the commander of the army and
he willfully did it.
And that's the grounds on which they actually impeached him
and put him on trial.
In the end,
he was acquitted not just because of skullduggery corruption and payments.
Yeah,
not entirely because of that at all.
He was acquitted in part because it was the spring of 1868
the Republican party was about to hold its nominating convention for the 1868
election.
Okay.
And they were about to nominate.
Everybody knew it.
You listen.
If they could just convince him to do it.
Ulysses grant,
as the next presidential candidate grant had been Johnson's general of the army
and Johnson kept embarrassing grant over and over and over until grant resign.
Okay.
And Republicans were suddenly frightened politically in the spring of 1868 if
they were really removed Johnson and put Ben Wade and the presidency and just
literally took over the government and it might really hurt them at the polls in
the fall and that Democratic Party was,
was doing everything under the sun,
including including using the Ku Klux Klan to a extent as we'll see in the next
two weeks to revive itself and oppose the Republicans in election after
election.
And will they ever in that 68 election in the spring of 68 oh good old age,
a promised better behavior too.
He said he'd,
he'd cool it,
he'd back off,
he'd get out of the way and he would never run again,
which wasn't quite true.
He was acquitted.
He served out his term.
He went home to East Tennessee and dead is all day.
Andy,
Andy Johnson always had,
he got back on the stump and he got himself reelected to the u s senate.
It will die in 1875 he's bearing Greenville,
Tennessee to this day and we're told he was buried with a copy of the
constitution on his chest,
held down by his hands.
He used to say he stood on the constitution and he's buried with the
constitution,
I guess standing on him.
Goodbye,
Andrew Johnson.
It's been so good to know you
now.
That fall,
the American people had a pivotal presidential election.
I know we say that about all great elections,
but let me give you the quick and dirty on 1868 phone or covers this nicely.
Grant was a war hero.
Of course,
he was going to be now the candidate of harmony.
We've had a lot of generals in our history run for president as candidates of
harmony.
When informed of his nomination,
which was only a few weeks after the acquittal trial in the Senate of Andrew
Johnson,
uninformed on May,
2018 68 of his,
uh,
excuse me.
In early June 80 68 of his nomination,
he issued a public statement,
which red eyes shall have no policy of my own to interfere against the will of
the people.
I'm going to repeat that.
You tell me what it means.
I still have no policy of my own to interfere against the will of the people.
Okay?
I will not take a stand.
He said in effect it exactly mean that.
But the slogan of it,
in the end of that statement,
uh,
with the,
the famous slogan that we become,
the slogan of his election campaign,
let us have peace.
This splendidly ambiguous slogan,
let us have peace and God knows the whole country's yearning for peace.
But what they would have in 1868 is by far the most,
the most racist white supremacist election in American history.
And by far to that date,
the most violent
granted committed to congressional control of reconstruction and to the
reconstruction acts.
But the party platform in 68 now retrenched into being a political persuasion of
order and stability and no longer have revolution and experiment.
They would now be protectors of the status quo.
They had created rather than the innovators in the experimenters.
They were now pillory by their opponents,
the Democrats as radicals as amalgamation,
just as miscegenation,
just
black suffrage.
The right to vote for black men became the issue of the 1868 election.
If you think the Democratic Party in the 1960s under Lbj,
which passes the 64 and 65 civil rights act put itself on a course of near
destruction in the south because of its liberal racial views,
which it did,
they'll,
Republicans of 1868 are now running on as the party of the black man's right to
vote.
No,
they did say that they were going to leave the right to vote to the whims of the
states in the north,
but in the south and that reconstruction act and by swallowing the 14th
amendment,
the Black Man's right to vote was supposed to be sacrosanct.
Yeah.
The Democratic Party at his convention in July of 68 and nominated Horatio
Seymour of New York.
It's former governor now Seymour had old,
among other things,
the Democrats,
Canada for president,
the vice president presidents of candidate gets worse,
but the Democratics Democrats,
presidential candidate and 68 Seymour had openly supported the draft rioters in
1863 in New York city or out slaughtering people in the streets.
He was on record for having a pose,
the civil war for having been a piece of Democrat in McAllen support or a man
who would've sued for peace with the south end.
He chose as his running mate Francis Frank Blair for vice president from
Missouri who was not only on open white supremacist,
but he declared that the Democrats would,
if elected announced the reconstruction acts,
Nolan void,
they would repeal them and they would return the south as immediately as
possible to home rule.
In other words,
if the Democrats were elected in [inaudible] 68 they would crush the
reconstruction plans
and Blair and his
blustery ways
even threatened a second civil war.
A little stupid there.
There were rhetoric and reality in 68 but what was the steak and 68 where the
results of the civil war?
It was a memory laden piece that was at stake.
Yeah.
The Democrats wanted to take the constitution backward.
The New York Herald,
the democratic paper asked quote,
was it the constitution as it was or the constitution as it is.
That's Andrew Johnson slogan.
Yeah.
Now I want to just give you an example or two of just how racist this campaign
was.
In 1868
there were bloody shirts waving everywhere.
Your people killed my people.
Blue blood on your hands is the blood of my son.
There were southern bloody shirts,
northern bloody shirts,
Democratic Party,
bloody shirts,
Republican party bloody shirts,
and African American bloody shirts symbolically,
and in some cases,
literally people would hold them up.
Here's Blair,
the vice president,
the attack dog on the campaign trail.
Republicans had a press,
the south claim,
Blair and one speech by subjecting it to the rule of a quote semi Barbour's race
of blacks who are polygamist and destined to subject white women to their
unbridled lust.
Let white men rule America,
screamed the headline and the Louisville newspaper
arguing the Republicans preferred quote,
native Negroes to native whites
in everywhere Democrats labeled the Republican Party as the party of quote,
the amalgamation of the races,
the monstrous Negro equality doctrine.
And on and on it went,
excuse me.
Uh,
Georgia Democrat
who got himself elected to the u s senate named Benjamin Hill,
said the south was now under the rule of a foreign power,
driven by hate and determined to dishonor an unarmed people.
Okay.
And in language understood across,
you might say all the white class lines in the south,
he announced that if the radicals controlled reconstruction,
southern whites would become America's new slaves.
They were said Benjamin Hill,
quote,
becoming the new Negros.
And on and on it went.
No Republicans gave it back.
Not Quite unkind,
but they certainly waved their bloody shirts.
Here's Wendell Phillips,
the old abolitionist in Boston who said,
quote,
in this election,
we have just finished the war between two ideas.
We send armies into South Carolina to carry our ideas.
If we had no right to carry our ideas,
we had no right to send our armies.
If the Democrats,
you know,
he said,
if Seymour wins this election,
it is as if Lee triumphs at Appomattox.
Okay.
That makes it pretty clear.
Or take this example of a kind of a black bloody shirt.
This is Benjamin Tanner,
the editor of the Christian record are the largest circulation black newspaper
in the United States.
It was the weekly newspaper of the African method,
African Methodist Episcopal church,
and he put it into a kind of little parable.
He says,
what's at stake in the 68 election?
This is a very gendered.
Of course,
when you think about the power and significance and blacks,
male suffrage,
you know exactly what he's aiming at.
Yeah.
He says,
Negro manhood is what is at stake in 68 here's the way he put it.
Negro manhood says,
I am an American citizen.
Modern democracy,
meaning the Democratic Party says you are not Negro man,
says Ida,
man,
all my rights,
civil and political.
Modern democracy says you have no rights except what I choose to give you.
Negro manhood says,
I must build churches from myself in school houses for my children.
Modern democracy says,
if you do,
I will burn them down.
Negro manhood says,
I will exercise the rights.
Vouchsafed okay.
Modern democracy says,
if you do,
I will mob and murder you.
Are you saying how are political campaigns get ugly?
God,
we are so tame
compared to this.
As someone once said,
politics is just war by other means and there's never a time when that is more
true than 1868
the Ku Klux Klan came into its own in 1868 I'm going to lecture in full about
violence in the clan.
Come next Thursday,
next week,
but 1868 was their first real coming out.
There was a reign of terror in five or six southern states in this election,
especially in Louisiana,
Georgia,
Arkansas and Tennessee
all across the south in [inaudible] 67 especially that election year 68 as well
and blacks are beginning to vow than to this process of tenant farming and
sharecropping and trying to eco livings.
They went to the polls and extraordinary numbers and risk their lives and many
of them died doing it.
There are all kinds of auxiliaries of the Democratic Party that really were the
Ku Klux Klan or its imitators.
There were more than 200 political murders in the state of Arkansas alone in
this election.
The death toll and Georgia was lower,
but intimidation at the polls was very effective.
In 22 Georgia counties with a total of 9,300 black men listed on the voting
rolls.
Grant tallied only 87 votes.
Oh,
Yep.
You're free to leave.
Okay.
Nice hair.
I hope he doesn't have a gun.
Okay.
At least he could have sung the lyric.
Seriously is that,
has that guy left
and the suffering continues
in Louisiana.
More than 1000 people died and political violence in this one election year,
almost all of them black,
all between April and November,
1868 in Louisiana,
21 parishes that had previously had a republican vote in 1867 totaling some
28,000 black voters.
Only 501 black votes got cast.
And these are just some examples of how intimidation worked.
Grand carried all of the north and 68 except three states.
If you count Oregon as a northern state,
the only northern states or the Seymour and the Democrats,
Carey were New Jersey and New York.
Seymour won three border states,
Delaware,
Maryland,
and Kentucky.
Okay.
Anyone?
Only two of the nine reconstructed x confederate states,
eight excuse me,
that were already re-admitted by 1868 grant won in the electoral college 214 to
80 the important thing is two things.
The Republican's sustained in the fall elections of 1868 a clear veto proof
congress,
two thirds in the house and four fifths in the Senate and without the
approximately half million African American men who voted for grant in those x
confederate states,
grant would never have been elected.
It was the first time in American history on the black vote mattered.
It counted
and so many of them voted in the face of threats to their lives.
Now on the ground in the south in the midst of all this politics and violence,
which we'll hear more about
in time,
a new level of did he say suffering?
One in place.
There was a speech made by a former confederate general at the American cotton
planters association meeting in late 1865 December [inaudible] 65 to be exact.
And at that meeting,
ironically,
it isn't exactly clear what he intended,
but at this meeting,
the former confederate general's name was Robert Richardson said,
quote,
the emancipated slaves own nothing because nothing but freedom has been given to
them.
They own nothing
because nothing but freedom was given to them in the absence of slavery.
What did the Friedman,
now think with me,
what did the Friedman actually own?
They own their bodies and they own their labor.
The freed people as a massive people at the end of the civil war.
Now,
I mean the jubilee has come,
but what are they actually have?
They lacked physical capital,
money,
land to some extent tools and they lacked to a certain degree,
human capital,
which means education,
literacy in certain kinds of skills.
A lot of slaves came out of slavery.
Of course with enormous skills,
blacks,
economic freedom though like their political freedom was largely at the mercy
of the regime of white society or of white supremacy itself.
However it would survive and the primary goal of white southerners from day one
of reconstruction all the way through was to try to sustain what they most
needed,
what whites most needed,
which was a landless dependent agricultural labor force that would stay put.
They wanted black people to remain,
if not slaves in status,
landless dependent and stationary as agricultural workers.
Put another way,
American freedom for American slaves brought no freedom.
Dude's if you've learned about indentured servitude in the past and the 18th
century in all the colonies,
there were always something called freedom dues.
When an indenture ended or former indentured servant got up suit of clothing,
a piece of cash and usually a piece of land
didn't happen.
There were attempts at this,
we'll see more about this in the coming two weeks
there was the Freedmen's bureau efforts to redistribute land to some extent.
There was.
That is Stevens is bill in 1867 which would have,
it didn't pass,
but it would have called for 40 acres and $50 there was no mention of a mule,
40 acres and $50 be given to each Friedman family by the federal government
across the south 40 acres.
It actually is sometimes referred to as the first reparations bill didn't pass.
There was Frederick Douglass,
his idea a little bit later of a national Friedman's loan agency,
a federal loan agency subsidized by the federal government by taxpayer money to
which Friedman would apply for loans,
perhaps three year loans,
five year loans,
low interest loans to buy land.
It's us.
It's the simplest idea in banking.
Didn't happen.
What did happen was a forth effort that became known as the Freedman's bank.
The Freedman's bank was chartered in late 1865 it lasted eight,
nine years.
It died in 1874 with obligations to approximately 61,000 depositers.
All former slaves are virtually all former slaves
and the bank died on Frederick Douglass,
his watch as its president because it could not make good on its payments.
It was a good idea
that really wasn't tried at the Freedman's bank,
by the way,
did have some congressional support.
It did have some federal subsidies,
but never enough to make it go or make it work.
Today we bail out bear Stearns in 1874 the federal government in the politics of
1874 is we'll see.
Just let the Freedman's bank die.
Now,
let me leave you with this.
I have I think a minute or so we've learned a great deal,
I think from the first and the second reconstructions in American history.
If we can refer to the civil rights movement as a second reconstruction.
We learned a great deal about how political liberty can be achieved.
The right to vote right the whole office,
serve on a jury,
engage in the political culture in spite of the hostility and the violence and
intimidation.
We've learned a great deal about how what can be achieved with political
liberty,
but we've also learned a lot about what is often not achieved in any kind of
concomitant economic power.
What happens now in the south is a rapid process from slave labor to a whole new
set of economic arrangements in the contract realm.
What blacks most wanted to get away from to kill off as they could was any old
system of gang labor.
They wanted control over the labor in lives of their women.
They wanted out of gang labor.
They want to plots of land of their own,
but they faced essentially these three great obstacles and I'll leave you with
this.
Yeah.
One is that they had inherited almost nothing from slavery with which to buy
land too.
They lived in a non almost nonexistent credit market.
Long term loans were simply not available anywhere and show me a farmer anywhere
in a capitalist economy who can survive without his bank loans
and three,
they face an enormously hostile regime of white supremacy that does not believe
black people should have economic independence.
And eventually what we see happening is the tenant farming and then working on
halves or thirds and then halves and working in a share cropping system becomes
a compromise.
It becomes a compromise because w paying wages to former slaves doesn't work in
an economy that is still cash poor.
There's no cash to pay anybody with,
so blacks actually begin to embrace this idea of being a tenant farmer because
you get your own plot of land,
you have some control over your own labor,
you plant your own seeds,
you own your own tools or you think you do.
At the end of the crop season,
you're going to,
you're going to share half of that crop.
We're the owner of the land and then with the furnishing merchant,
this new institution that evolves,
but you get to keep half and you can at least hope they didn't.
That half comes something like cash that you can keep
what it really is going to become.
However,
for most not all is a dead end to some extent a dead end kind of debt.
Peonage.
What we do know is this over the next 25 to 30 years,
by about 1890 and certainly by 1900 about 15 to 20% of American Friedman and
their sons and daughters will own their own land.
It means about
80% to 85% did not.
I'll leave you there and suffer on.